non mais moi aussi empêché soulage
rapidement il faut que tu y ait aussi
très bien vous montrer un peu ce que
j'ai appris à benghazi allons-y
en fait mais vous montrer en corse
enlevé en utilisant un trombone assez
d'accord et est ce qu'on attend du
beurre du barça du berceau du beurre et
un tron ancien utilise sens très bien je
préfère la haye ok je croise à ok alors
attention ne sont pas le rosbif ok alors
qu'anthony votre photothèque alice sont
dotés de disques à 0 attention on va
passer pour des cons
mon allemand a doublé à 3 5 minutes car
je suis sur ibrahim
il a la clé tout au moins libère moi moi
parce que quand même reporté ce cas ça
[Applaudissements]
continue je suis en mode ip au vote
on va aux toilettes on revient tout de
suite hein elle sera de retour bientôt
pas bien où sont les toilettes les plus
proches
il est bon mais moi aussi empêché
soulage rapidement il faut que tu y ait
aussi très bien bon ne nous prîmes pas
là voila voila type de faire ça avec un
avec quelqu'un d'autre ça que je le
plains j'arrive à étoiles rouges proches
amis l'ont vraiment sorti leur zizi
[Applaudissements]
via texto la team de noby me passe une
épingle à nourrice
je vais là fidèle assistant real au cas
où une épingle à nouveau la colère
[Applaudissements]
attention là ce qui suit le serrurier
pour de vrai nom mais sans équivoque et
les chevriers témoin micro monsieur
rappaz déjà là attendez attendez vous
pratiquez les circoncisions vous êtes je
suis rapport mois non ça y est vous êtes
serrurier sonné chez moi je sais tout
c'est le voisin car n'a jamais été mise
et au pain pour les jumelles à la main
rouler gaffuri de muscles mais il est
trop vous êtes allez les gars allez les
heroes hausse à 0,4 parce que là tu es
en train de faire un cadeau tu vas faire
défaut merci tu verras
[Applaudissements]
sur la tête de ma mère chantait je suis
pas l'homme qu'un viol est de faire j'en
ai pas mal je bouffais 7 trophy les gars
je n'ai pas content tu as tu n'as jamais
la m la hague à cotonou il comptera l'on
connaît pas on sait pas qui c'est le
gars il est en train de racheter à ma
place moi tu vas faire un jeux pan non
mais comment on va faire la fête de
confiance arrête de poser la question va
l'ouvrir
on va couper la main avant de retirer la
lourdeur trop de van ainsi ses traits
sièges
bush la branche la main et cammalleri
fois sûr et bouge pas parce qu avant de
couper la main
c'est mon poêle à bois guillaume mais
oui c'était des témoins ben justement si
je rate mon coup c'est fini bah oui dans
toute chance de bien moi je cours vite
maintenant mais pas de faire des 9e
coupe la main ça coupe le 3 mai les
facteurs attention images parce qu'il
est très serré un bar est de toucher aux
connaisseurs et monsieur monsieur très
rassurant oui alors allez-y toucher les
cas y'a pas la clé son ami le maire ça
fait ça fait c'est le gars qui dit y'a
pas la clé là c'est à dire qu'il est pas
sûr de lui non ça marche pas et
étudiants les conneries c'est la torah
dont le mois à temps je ne dis pas que
c'est la clé soirée merci c'est la curée
non si c'est la craie cyril virez les
tous
regarde aucun manga aucun si c'est la
clé non mais à mon avis c'est l'autre
qui vous la donner ah oui là ils
affaibliraient non fois alors sans
déconner quoi il a fait exprès on la
coupe la clé tiens tiens très vives ont
déjà tâté venu pour rien toi non je suis
contenu pour rien hu a bobo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]